hey youtubers it's charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's arrow and flash crossover
episodes as well as all the suicide
squad stuff too so i'm gonna try and
address all that stuff during this video
i got a lot of comments on deadpool
about why i wasn't doing a suicide squad
video it's mostly just a time thing i
already do a lot of dc videos during the
week so if i did more dc movie videos it
would be like dc all the time so i just
try to squeeze it in whenever i can
unless like new footage drops then i hit
like a giant muppet alarm button and
stop the presses important stuff first
though so everyone's asking when all the
shows are coming back in the spring
technically it's still the winner but
flash is back on january 20th that's
basically like the third week in january
arrows just back the next day after that
arrow isn't confirmed they're probably
going to come back at the same time
though so question time these will be
just a mixture of suicide squad arrow
flash questions so number one zenzord
asks is the suicide squad deadshot dead
now so i assume you're talking about
arrow's version of deadshot no he's
totally fine the actually the actor that
placed him went into the office i think
he was posting pictures on instagram
earlier this year he'll appear the next
time they have a suicide squad episode
they've actually had a couple name drops
just because they dropped cupid off
there a couple of episodes ago we will
totally see them in the back half of the
season i would say in terms of the movie
you know yeah they're probably a couple
characters they're just gonna sidestep
but the movies and the tv show can do
whatever they want within reason they're
really only a couple characters that are
off limits like harley quinn is a bit of
a no-no in joker obviously they can't do
the tv show that is aside from that as
long as they're characters that aren't
like super overexposed like they aren't
appearing in a bunch of other films or
animated movies it's usually totally
okay for them to use new characters it's
really just a question of budget like if
they have the money to hire the actors
to play whatever role they want if you
guys ever wonder why they don't want
like the same character to be on tv and
in the movies too like batman for
instance it's because of overexposure
like that's what they're worried about a
really good example is disney with r2d2
so he was supposed to be in the lego
movie but disney said that they didn't
want to overexpose him the people that
actually wrote the movie had already
like written this big part for r2d2 it
was going to be really cool but disney
said no way so they couldn't do it which
is actually kind of hilarious because
warner brothers let batman be in the
lego movie sometimes the logic doesn't
always make sense but stephen amell said
that he had a lot of meetings with the
movie people and they kind of explained
how they make decisions and he was
fairly satisfied so if he's satisfied
then i can totally deal with it we could
totally do a bonus video about that at
some point about the way the business
happens at warner brothers between the
film and tv divisions in contrast to
marvel it's actually pretty interesting
but it's really businessy question
number two sergio ass super powers on
arrow canary cry anyone
you had like a series of question marks
after that so i took it as a question so
mark guggenheim originally said no
superpowers on arrow but he's recently
changed his mind his hard and fast role
was no superpowers on arrow it was made
to be like the christopher nolan dark
knight trilogy a very gritty realistic
crime drama with superhero characters in
it so the superhero part was always
secondary to the characters in the crime
drama like the character development
there's the superhero moments like
whenever they're like punching people
and capturing villains then there's the
character moments whenever they're just
talking to each other so far the
strategy has totally paid off for them
but i think now that they're getting on
in seasons they're just able to have a
little bit more fun with themselves take
it like a little less seriously it's
like they're inching toward that
shawarma type moment where it's just
completely ridiculous i think tv has a
little easier job with that than the
films do because there's not so much
money involved it's just easier for them
to take chances because they have 23
episodes a season versus just a one
single like two and a half hour movie
just in terms of like the next super
powered person i'd like to see on aero i
mean i'd like to see ray palmer get his
adam powers like his shrinking powers
they said that they were gonna do the
atom suit but they weren't gonna do some
of the more comic book-y aspects of his
powers most notably the shrinking part
like they would save that if he went on
the flash there was potential for ray
palmer's character to go into the flash
in season two now a lot of people are
lobbying for him to stay on arrow during
season four they haven't made a decision
yet i mean they've started to plot out
season four based on what stephen amella
said they haven't even finished
production on season three yet though
and they haven't been picked up for
season four officially so it's all just
like in the ether right now so if
anything crazy with superpowers ends up
happening on arrow that we haven't
already seen just think in the direction
of the atom question number three bmc
zero zero will the announcement of the
suicide squad movie affect future
appearances on arrow harley quinn wasn't
sure about deadshot and the rest
uh i kind of already answered some of
that i mean
largely not really beyond those big big
you know a-list characters if it's a
character that's already appeared on the
show like if they've already established
the character deadshot being the best
example they're not going to go back on
that they'll still let them use that
character and when i say they i mean the
film division letting the tv division do
it the film division has a little bit
more say just because it's a little more
profitable there's a lot more money
behind it so they treat it a lot more
carefully than they treat the tv
division it's kind of like walking on
superhero eggshells around each other
which is a good reason about why i don't
want to work in hollywood that bad
question for jamie asks am i the only
one who was wondering how boomerang got
into the arrow cave and why anyone else
didn't think about how he got in
yeah they kind of brushed over that so
what happened is is stephen meller
oliver took the phone after torturing
the guy the phone was fake it was meant
to trace back the location of the arrow
cave so whenever they were analyzing it
inside the arrow cave captain boomerang
traced the signal back that's how he
found the arrow cave your reaction was
the same reaction that i had i was like
wow there are so many people that have
found the arrow cave now this is gonna
become a big thing if you watched any of
my videos from last season like if you
were a subscriber last season i actually
predicted that they might have a new
aerocave just because they pretty much
destroyed the foundry and they didn't
even own verdan anymore i think there
are a couple reasons why they stayed
with the arrow cave they do have right
now most notably being their set design
budget i mean it costs a lot of money to
build that set you don't really see it
but there's like light rigs and there's
everything for where the cameras sit so
you get up into like the couple million
dollars whenever you build big sets like
that you know for example doctor who i
think the tardis that they built cost
between like two and four million
dollars i think it was closer to two but
that's a lot of money in fact i'll say
that's probably like the number one
reason by far it's just they don't have
the money or they don't want to spend
millions of dollars it would cost to
build another arrow cave question number
five cw pre asks who is your number one
guess for who the reverse flash is now
that we know or the writers want us to
know that eddie or wells is not going to
be who that is so yeah there was an
image posted where eddie and wells are
looking at the reverse flash so it's
very clearly not one of them as we know
them on the show that doesn't mean that
it couldn't be a future version of them
it just means that the characters that
we're seeing on the show right now we've
been saying week to week are not going
to be the reverse flash that we see in
episode nine so number one pick i'll say
it's professor zoom they'll go with ao
bar thon from the future like the far
future my number two pick would be a
relative of one of the characters on the
show i will say andrew kriesberg has
made official comments that it's really
not someone that everyone has been
talking about so like all the most
common things that everyone's been
talking about he said it's not those
people so just think in terms of like
big twists like what is like a big twist
that you have not thought of yet my
first thought was like a dark version of
barry but i don't think that that's what
it is and we're not gonna find out who
it is like we won't find out which
character it is for a long time at least
till the back half of the season
question six shadow wolf ass do you
think the calculator could show up on
arrow someone who operates like a
worldwide communications network like a
founding member of the secret society of
super villains he's also been a member
of the fearsome five and he usually
fights the birds of prey so yeah i think
that's totally possible he's actually
you know a super villain who has fairly
realistic powers i mean he's like a
cyber terrorist there's also an episode
called canaries in the back half of the
season i think that's mostly going to be
a flashback episode because katie lott
said she was filming scenes for it katie
lotz was actually supposed to be in
three episodes this season and we saw
her in the first two the third one was
supposed to be a flashback i think it'll
be just showing a little bit of
backstory about how she became the
canary the first time with the league of
assassins just think of it as a twist on
the christopher nolan bruce wayne origin
story with the league question number
eight gerard do you actually make a
comment about you know which superhero
one arrow of the flash so yeah it's like
a batman versus superman situation and
it's always gonna be batman oliver
always gonna be like the dark hero
because they don't pull punches the
reason why batman can beat superman is
is because superman is never going to
kill anyone i mean i should say he's
never going to try to kill anyone that's
not why i think that oliver is always
going to be barry i think it's just
because barry's such a rookie at this
point i think i already made the analogy
but it's like barry is driving a really
really fast car without knowing how to
drive so he's gonna lose every single
race he gets into and in this case the
race is like a fist fight in the world
of superheroes like there's a wide
disparity in the level of power each
superhero super villain has so it's
really just a matter of who's the most
experienced fighter that's why slade
wilson the deathstroke is always able to
kick the justice league's butt or at
least the slate of the comics the slate
of the arrowverse just isn't quite there
yet so now to answer some big suicide
squad questions so i'm just going to
answer the biggest ones right away
obviously the most interesting casting
is jared leto as the joker he's an
amazing actor in terms of his
performance i have no idea what it's
going to look like like if you watch
dallas buyers club he's amazing in that
as a transvestite he can disappear into
roles so i think he'll be able to
disappear into the joker the same way
that heath ledger did but they're
obviously going to be very different
versions of that character i will give
him the benefit of the doubt even the
actors that i don't like like for
instance harley quinn i'm not a huge fan
of the actress that plays her character
but i'll give her the benefit of the
doubt if you look at the cast i mean yes
it's an ensemble film but there will be
leads most notably tom hardy and jared
leto that was when they were first
talking about suicide squad you heard
tom hardy's name first because they had
to get that big a-list actor like the
really awesome guy to attract all the
other people that's how a lot of movies
get made it's really funny david ayer
the director is arguably his best film
is supposed to be fury which i have not
seen yet if you have a chance to see it
at some point you should it'll be good
template for some of the energy that he
might bring to suicide squad that's
going to be a very different kind of
movie but thematically they just tend to
pick directors based on things they
think they do really well and fury is
kind of like a wartime ensemble film
because tom hardy's playing the rick
flag character i'm actually wondering if
they're going with an even more classic
version of the suicide squad like
there's the modern version of the
suicide squad and then there's like the
1980s like pretty like the really old
version of the suicide squad most of my
experience with the team has been with
the post identity crisis suicide squad
like you know post 2000 just in terms of
characters crossing over the biggest
potential is for jared leto's joker to
appear in the other films he doesn't
really exist inside the batman superman
universe that zack snyder is developing
right now but he will presumably at some
point it's really more of a superman
driven film at this point than it is a
batman film that's why you haven't seen
like a batman solo film on the schedule
yet just because i think most of the
focus is behind henry cavill right now
not ben affleck although ben affleck was
like a huge deal to cast if there is a
future batman solo film i do feel like
ben affleck will get a crack at
directing it and writing the script he's
a great writer great director it's just
like watching what his batman looks like
that's the big question mark so don't
forget air on the flash mid-season
finales next week be sure to subscribe
to get my videos if you haven't already
i will totally do bonus videos while
they're away it's only going to be six
weeks they'll be off the air in the
meantime if you're on your mobile phone
or your tablet you can click up here for
extra links it's the same as the links
over here but click here for my arrow
episode 8 video for the brave and the
bold and click here for the flash versus
zero thank you so much for watching so
that's all high five i will see you guys
tomorrow